take me back to you guys taking on
Rappers Delight because another terrible
uh I have to admit that I'm I I only
knew the death squad Rappers Delight so
even when I even to this day like I I
know the OG Rappers Delight but even to
this day like when I see like when the
OG Rappers Delight comes on I sing the
the death squad
what was that like did you guys
initially get any sort of like blowback
for like reming such heralded record
listen it wasn't something to do it was
it was a project M that went on MTV yeah
yeah and um they had all the groups pick
old records oh so you guys pick that
that was kind of the theme of the
project so masterp did 6 in the morning
whatever that it's called in the
beginning okay oh I remember the the the
the there was like the knuckles with the
Rings
IB in the beginning everybody did
something on there so when they came and
got us this is what we chose cuz it was
three of us three y not knowing that it
was going to shoot a video MTV number
one video like we had no IDE brought the
record back like we we beat Maxwell by
10,000 records to be number one album in
the country crazy death squad went
number Uno yeah you know because of what
that was but we didn't do it on purpose
but we did get um blowback from the
original people cuz don't think they
still torn with it yeah so now the death
squad then came and now it took away
from them it took a long time for them
to be like yo cuz now we're not see like
yo what's up everything is love but at
one time H wasn't [__] with it at
first right because it's going to stop
them from from from moving around yeah
you know we don't know that I feel like
the other way to look at it is like
thanks for putting some more life into
this song and but that's what eventually
happened yeah cuz like there did you see
the Grammys Tracy Chapman performed with
uh this country singer who she has a
song called Fast Car from like 1988 I
know JC JC yeah yeah and uh this this
country singer covered it wow and like
it was a huge country song but they did
it at the Grammys and so now Tracy
Chapman's song from 1988 no it's number
one one now it's number one it's crazy
it's like but believe me I was telling
my man the other day like and this this
it's not no no b or nothing yeah but um
me owning my own
everybody calls me so if it was for all
the 50 Cent shows you know whatever my
placements they got to call me direct I
was telling my man
that music I mean the weekend is one of
the most streaming artists in the world
100% right so him and Metro
boomman did I don't want to know
creeping yeah Y which is you a customer
M right y only owe 4% of that 4% of that
of that
record right 4%
of the
original of no of that record of Metro
boomman of of of you a customer on that
song so you own 4% of creeping of of of
the publishing
right listen every four months guess how
much it brings in uh $200,000 2220
wow that's crazy y y yo but that's 240
but that's that's crazy he was on the
money he's in it yeah
4% Eric talk about track Liv track wait
hold on so let me get this straight so
when you because do you have to hear the
song first before you clear it yes even
when they when they did the Mad singer
and the Mad somebody on the Mad singer
sung did the record yeah mad singer
called me wow everybody has to call
because again everybody's not fortunate
cuz luckily Leo con and his brother made
me made me me
and what them made me me so I didn't
have to sell the publishing cuz people
sell publishing when they when they need
to get the money so luckily I was able
to survive without doing that for you
like uh I think most people don't
understand the how important the pub
game is because we always are pushed
like well the streaming only pays this
if you get a million streams it's like
3,800 bucks but like the real money is
really in the pub right like if you can
like own your publishing let's back this
up yeah even though streaming might be
less than one cent it's still more money
being made than you signed to a
label it's still more money being made
if you don't sign to a label is what
you're saying if you signed to a label
and you and and and and and you are
independent
streaming you is a chance that you can
make more money than being on a major
exactly yeah for sure even with the less
than one penny yeah it's it's rough cuz
you I mean but but but but people don't
know if you're not in the game you
wouldn't know that but I have a
streaming company so I I I'm witness to
what it makes right but on the pub side
though like cuz I feel like the
publishing side of music is not talked
about enough and I also feel like oh no
people know that why you what you've
seen all the arguments with the locks
and puff and everybody with publishing
that's a always been a big deal no I
mean I'm just talking about this new
these new kids man oh they don't have a
clue they have no idea because it's the
360 asthma they'll just come in they'll
be like how much is my Advance yeah
that's it yeah and then they be like oh
[__] I don't know my Masters or my [__]
or they'll rush into a pub deal they
they they'll get one placement and then
everybody hear what Kevin is talking
about cuz Kev don't got to do this but
he is doing this he's just trying to not
to to to to to downplay y'all but to let
y'all know what y'all have to do because
this thing is not going to is not a
lasting thing at this time this we
liveing in moments times of popularity
where things that fast food every new
every hour something is coming yep yeah
and if you catch one placement as a
producer proder someone's going to offer
you a c-pub deal not an admin deal and
that c-pub deal it could be I mean that
means you're full partners with a
publishing company and it could be 10
years it could be in perpetuity it could
be a lot of different things other
people so about the 401K or you TI It
plan this is what publishing is it's
it's your life if you're able to have
some of it please grab as much as you
can cuz you're going to get that mailbox
money every all the time it it never
stops and then all of a sudden you might
catch a placement
like I just told you yeah which is crazy
how many years later I know but but it
happens but I'm just giving you one yeah
this happens all the time yeah I'm just
giving you one thing about having
publishing and what it can do for you
for sure man